il est très énervé
enlève ta main enlève comment il va
attaquer alliés face à un gros mal de
plus d'un mètre soixante dix les indiens
l'appel naja cobra lunettes à cause du
dessin qu'il a dans le doubs où c'est
vous laissez moi la trappe est
tenu par là que le naja n'a pas la force
de se relever ni d'attaqués
par respect pour l'animal ali se
présente à lui
tu as bien dans ses toits des halles et
danse pour moi
c'est dangereux un cobra mais je n'y
pense jamais
une fois capturés je le considère comme
mon propre enfant et je le traite comme
tel je joue avec lui je le nourris et je
les ducs reste bien droit voilà reste
calme
comme ça